je vais le faire rentrer maintenant à
proposera d'autres questions à Sophie
parce qu'après il doit repartir il a le
mariage de la fille Jennifer
Jennifer torza et de Mounir benchetritz
voilà donc il va venir tout de suite
allez ramène-toi
[Applaudissements]
bonne soirée
c'est bon ça va bien c'est rigolo
n'hésitez pas à contacter moi ça va et
vous
voyez
mon fils je peux pas
je ne me régler mes démêler avec lui en
coulisse allez qu'est-ce que tu veux
faire là une chronique par exemple une
chronique est-ce que tout le monde va
bien vous allez bien
ou pas ce que ça va changer pour toi
c'est ma première donnée je suis très
content pour moi c'est le seul gars qui
a fait quand même des interviews cet été
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la première chronique de l'année
vous l'avez dit et qui dit première
chronique je suis obligé de revenir
alors pour dire pour ceux qui savent pas
ma chronique c'est quoi je monte ce qui
se passe en off pendant les pubs pendant
les magnétos bref ce que vous ne voyez
pas à la télé et il y a quelque chose
que vous n'avez pas vu vous à la maison
c'est le pilote le pilote c'est une
émission test mon cul
c'est une émission test c'est c'est une
émission où vous testez les chroniqueurs
les nouvelles séquences etc enfin plutôt
les pilotes cette année les pilotes
parce que Cyril je sais pas vous lui
avez beaucoup manqué cette année il a
fait 74 pilotes qu'on durait deux jours
qu'en durée 10 commandements il a testé
850 chroniqueurs et comme à chaque début
de série chaque début de pilote
qu'est-ce que vous faites et tu devrais
faire des exercices du bled
[Rires]
de pilote que fait Cyril donc il vient
et il débrief le décor c'est le prénom
de l'histoire des lancements
quel est ton projet
prendre mon chèque et faire une
chronique
3h à débriefer le décor c'est le retour
d'un abonnement de patron
mais c'est catastrophique comme retour
vous avez décidé d’être sympathique un
jour bleu rouge regardez comment il est
beau l'écran c'est la France le blanc
aussi
il s'enfonce à chaque fois il en rajoute
c'est la technique Isabelle Morini boss
non mais c'est vrai
ça continue
[Musique]
au départ il voulait faire un napping
sur le changement de décor
et je suis arrivé il dit bon c'est pas
qu'ils ont rajouté un toboggan là
non mais ça sans déconner les gars on se
croirait dans un film érotique le
dimanche
[Applaudissements]
donc là j'ai ce que vous faites vous
appelez la chef déco du plateau
Géraldine et Cyril vous avez une qualité
vous êtes le roi du compliment
c'est toi qui a eu l'idée de ces vis
s'apparente c'est quoi le délire c'est
en cercueil en fait c'est pour Daniel
tu vas partir
non mais ce n'est que les anciens
chroniqueurs
oui vous avez un avis aiguisé sur le
décor Cyril normal pour un spécialiste
de l'ameublement
mais déjà il y a une différence entre
votre desk et les desk et des
chroniqueurs vous l'avez vu le mien le
mec fait surtout vieux tapant
moi direct je suis dans un camion au
bois de Boulogne en train d'attendre des
clients
oui Cyril vous êtes un homme de défi de
rien vous le transformez en challenge et
ça c'est fort je vais te dire on va
faire quelque chose jamais fait on va se
mettre des handicaps
et on va garder ce décor
un homme de défi enfin le décor aura
duré 48 heures et pourtant c'est pas
faute d'avoir prévenu
deux minutes frère je kiffe pas comme ça
est-ce que là je peux pas passer
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on passe maintenant au placement des
chroniques alors pour ceux qui sont déjà
mariés à la maison vous savez le
placement des tables au mariage chez une
tanasse pas possible
mais tous les ans pour placer les
chroniqueurs ça peut durer très très
longtemps regardez
je vous remercie d'être là tout le monde
est content oui vous êtes bien là tu
vois
ça moi je suis pas bien là l'important
dans l'émission c'est que moi je sois
bien
justement Cyril combien ça prend le
temps pour que vous soyez bien 4 heures
4h30 on regarde
sur la tête de ma mère vous avez mal
casser les couilles on va tous changer
pas du tout laissez-moi faire on va
tirer au sort les places et bien le
grand perdant c'est Raymond puisque ça
fait poncerrir tous les dés mais pour
être proche de lui par contre il
retourne à la case départ tourner à la
case départ
bon là ça fait deux heures qu'on joue
aux chaises musicales on se dit qu'on va
enfin pouvoir commencer le pilote quand
même
non non mais les mecs ce pilote ça sera
que ça que les places non mais je vous
dis je vous connais j'ai pas besoin je
connais la table bon là maintenant on a
un Bernard pas content arrêt mon
perspicace ce placement table n'en finit
plus c'est un art est un peu loin quand
même je suis trop loin non mais les mecs
on est 10 on sera 9h ouh là ou là ou
chez lui voilà voilà
[Rires]
dans quelle émission vous voyez un gars
du public qui se mêle du décor c'est pas
un gars du Fou
s'il te plaît excuse-moi tu es qui toi
bon au final on sait tous comment ça va
finir cette histoire écoutez gilberté ce
qui est pour une fois dit pas une
connerie et mecs si jamais besoin de
vous je le saurai maintenant quel tirage
au sort vous allez faire la table comme
vous l'entendre
il est là regardez il est là il est
encore là
comment ça va mon chéri ça va et toi mon
Cyril je suis content de te voir on a
discuté ensemble sur sur X après
l'émission
c'est un très bon journaliste un très
beau papier et voilà c'est vraiment mon
chéri la table te va
ouais si Sophie Raymond parfait alors
Sophie elle va pas rester là pour hein
merci mon chéri elle était très bien tu
es encore mieux coiffé que sur le pilote
non c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
argent
[Applaudissements]
un petit spectacle Guillaume la Chine
[Rires]
dans le thème de l'amour Cyril et vous
avez testé une chroniqueuse qui
s'appelle Moon exactement Moon une
petite nouvelle donc mais il y a une
chose que vous ignorez sur les petits
nouveaux Cyril ils ont le zigouni en feu
oui j'ai des images
[Musique]
et très content d'être là merci mon
petit mot comme ça mon chéri je suis en
pleine forme et Mouna
[Rires]
elle le connaît mais pourquoi
connait-elle donc ce chroniqueur c'était
des haines sont instants en 2019 non
c'est pas vrai
2019 t'as répondu le 27 mars 2020
et là c'est le babata qui entre en jeu
vous prenez le téléphone du chroniqueur
vous lisez ses DM la discrétion incarnée
en tout cas sincèrement je pense pas ce
que tu as envie ce que tu as envie
d'être ah ouais non c'est lui qui a
écrit ça oh là là il y a le meilleur
j'ai un dossier j'ai la première
oh le bâtard oh là ok l'horreur la
phrase est folle non sans aucune drague
ou mauvais esprit tu es vraiment
magnifique
mais en plus de en l'air sa
chronique Cyril vous lui foutez en l'air
son couple vous êtes vraiment un chic
patron vous
ah ouais il y a un vrai bail 2019
c'était une année voilà j'ai envie de
faire des remplaces
[Rires]
les chroniques testés il y en a une que
je vous supplie de prendre c'est pas le
cas ah ouais si elle était recrutée je
peux faire des chroniques toute l'année
j'ai de la matière jusqu'au mois de juin
c'est une chroniqueuse pas comme les
autres
ça va pas oui
tu fais quoi toi ben moi j'ai arrêté en
pleine reconstructionnelle par contre tu
faisais des photos on peut résumer ça du
contenu pour adulte
non mais c'est vrai que c'est du coup tu
pourras adulte on va pas des Télétubbies
si on voit pas on voit des topisses
là c'est vrai que cette polka elle est
pétillante par contre elle n'a pas
compris comment vous étiez au niveau des
ailes Cyril
[Musique]
30 40 comme ça
non franchement en plus c'est dur d'être
chroniqueuse dans TPMP parce qu'il faut
savoir utiliser la pancarte et tout et
ça c'est relou
et voilà
on va revenir profondément tout deuxième
débat deuxième tanasse ça fonctionne
toujours pas au niveau de la pancarte je
crois que là ça passe pas
c'est logique une fois qu'on a
pas d'elle
[Musique]
c'est pour ça qu'on en parle voilà
bon au final Cyril TPMP ça reste TPMP
que des numéros 10
[Musique]
en fait j'arrive pas à trouver avec mes
ongles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les pilotes il y a tout et n'importe
quoi surtout n'importe quoi c'est la
Gazette du offre du pilote
[Musique]
tout d'abord dans un bon pilote il y en
a un qui est toujours prêt à tout pour
gagner sa place cette année c'est
Monsieur Philippe carient il a tout
compris on veut savoir plus sur toi
qu'est-ce que tu faisais toi bah ça fait
17 ans que je suis un canal ouais mais
avant je fais une maîtrise de droit mais
toute façon j'avais qu'un seul rêve dans
la vie c'était bosser avec toi
dans un bon pilote vous oubliez toujours
le nom des gars en même temps normal si
vous testez 367 personnes
c'est pas de ta faute Solène mais je te
dis au soleil
[Musique]
en vacances
[Rires]
dans un bon pilote Cyril on a toujours
un qui est une qui s'est pris un gros
coup de soleil pendant l'été sauf que
cette année c'est pas la bonne
ah mais je suis au moins tu me fais
craquer
quand même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toute la journée tu mets la télévision
tu mets Roland doute il y a du partout
il y a des chats
[Applaudissements]
merci